[Música]
hola a todos bienvenidos a los
observadores de france 24 en rusia la
letra zeta se ha convertido en un
símbolo de apoyo a la guerra en ucrania
desde la cuenta de instagram del
ministerio de defensa ruso hasta los
reinos un poco más allá del círculo
polar ártico también se utiliza para
intimidar a aquellos que no apoyan la
guerra imagínense llegar a su casa y que
en su puerta haya una letra z con un
mensaje que dice no traiciones a tu
patria a dima team a ese dmitri y vano
de 22 años él es estudiante en la
universidad estatal de moscú ms allí
administra un canal de tele msv protesta
la primera vez había un graffiti que
decía no traiciones a tu patria dima
la segunda vez había un cartel con una
foto mía sacada de internet y los
números de las nuevas leyes de censura
militar que amenazaba quienes difunden
información o se expresan contra la
guerra
spain
lo mismo le sucedió al menos cuatro
activistas anti guerra en moscú la misma
letra zeta con el mismo mensaje
y dos semanas después el mismo afiche
con la palabra colaborador impresa a lo
largo de la foto
[Música]
la primera vez estaba muy sorprendido
porque no todos los días viene alguien a
vandalizar tu puerta no es muy agradable
es como decir sabemos dónde vives
podemos ir a tu casa con total impunidad
originalmente la letra zeta era sólo un
símbolo militar técnico
ahora lo utilizan todos los que apoyan
la intervención en ucrania los
estudiantes los funcionarios
los niños en los hospitales se colocan
en forma de z
[Música]
pero la letra zeta también ha sido
apropiada por algunos activistas para
denunciar la guerra en ucrania se puede
encontrar por ejemplo en los grafitis
contra la guerra que han sido
compartidos en telégrafo
he visto carteles con la letra zeta en
la palabra mal en la palabra fascismo
la gente intenta relacionar este símbolo
con asociaciones negativas pero
consideró que ya es negativo
[Música]
qué significa esta letra zeta es una
esvástica al menos en eso se ha
convertido se parece un poco a la mitad
de una esvástica y se utiliza de la
misma manera puede intimidar a algunas
personas pero personalmente no me asusta
me daría más miedo una visita oficial de
la policía
este tipo objetivo en este música banco
pilotos más
a este hombre se le acusa de intentar
robar equipos informáticos en ucrania en
la ciudad de camiones que desde el
comienzo de la guerra en ucrania en
internet han sido publicadas decenas de
imágenes que muestran las personas
atadas a árboles y a postes en la calle
nuestra redacción ha podido geolocalizar
17 de estas escenas ocurrieron en
diferentes ciudades del país muy a
menudo para castigar a personas acusadas
de robo de tiana pies jones y trabaja
para una ong de derechos humanos y nos
explica por qué se cometen estos
castigos en su país
las personas atadas a los postes son
acusadas de saqueo ordena a veces son
golpeados o se les quita la ropa a veces
les ponen mensajes que dicen que son
saqueadores
inter
y
la gente está desesperada esto es una
masacre muchas personas se ven obligadas
a abandonar sus hogares
nos encontramos en una situación en la
que no hay suficientes policías
presentes porque muchos se alistaron en
el ejército o en las fuerzas de defensa
territorial por eso si la gente ve que
hay saqueos o robos trata de impedir los
por la fuerza
esto no es apropiado pero
desgraciadamente ocurre desde el punto
de vista legal si hay saqueadores o no
hay policía en el lugar la gente tiene
derecho a retener a los supuestos
saqueadores para que no se escape por
entonces tienen que llamar a la policía
para que venga a detener a la persona
nos va a exponer
para bien hemos visto casos de personas
brigadas y torturadas casos de trato
inhumano y esto lo condenamos firmemente
es muy probable que estos castigos se
infligen a veces de forma espontánea por
ciudadanos ordinarios o por las fuerzas
de seguridad ucranianas pero las
autoridades a veces también apoyan este
tipo de castigos como la policía
nacional que publicó estas fotos y
explicó que todos los saqueadores
deberían ser detenidos humillados y
castigados
es todo por esta semana en los
observadores de france 24 si usted
quiere entrar en comunicación con la
producción del programa todos nuestros
datos de contacto aparecen en sus
pantallas esperamos todas sus imágenes y
sus vídeos nosotros nos vemos la próxima
semana en otro episodio de los
observadores hasta entonces